[Music]
break
[Music]
so
did you in a million years like ever
think
or see any of this when you were
fighting no god like just sitting here
like god no no
god no
no i mean now do you when you're gonna
when you're about to watch this what do
you think
anxiety even though i know how these go
and i didn't pick the fight so it's like
reliving trump yeah i've had you know i
had over ten we've count ultimate fight
we could watch ultimate fighter that'd
be fun to re-watch ultimate fighter
together important you hear that one
mike actually we should definitely do
that rewatch i've never seen the whole
thing i'd love to do it yeah and i have
all the insight the background on that
but because back then people don't
realize that i i was with you when this
would happen you'd just be a sign of
oh
a
fighter
beside my mom no lex who's lex would
call you still i'm sure you're fighting
buddy
there you go amigo we got one what do we
got he said you got crow cop i'm like oh
wow okay well better get to work
so uh i didn't pick these fights the
squad picked the fights
i would assume you guys picked all the
ones that i've won we're only watching
three these aren't long like your
traditional fight campaign these will be
about 20 30 minutes long
so you guys pick chase gormley chris
tushasher
and
mirko krokop
three fun fights next time we do this
we'll we should toss in some of the ones
i lost not a lot but we'll toss those in
sure why not so let's kick it off with
chase gormley now what's interesting
about this
is chase gormley was my first fight look
at that young man 6-3 265 yeah so chase
yeah so chase gary was my first fight
after coming up
my first official ufc fight coming off
the loss to roy nelson on the ultimate
fighter finale this fight was stressful
a it's in broomfield event center where
i actually started my mma career so i
was familiar with it i was the first
fight on the card i was on the prelims
as the first fight now i want you to
notice ufc is not like this anymore
notice how full the crowd is yeah the
boys the local hometown favorite so they
did it on purpose
and that's so that that's uh you know aj
mckee that's his dad
oh wow aj mccube's the bellator champ
that's his dad he was finding out a
place called i think the fight shop or
something like that but the interesting
thing about chase gormley size his head
is the size of a water buffalo yep and
um now right now i'm watching you now
right now what's you're you're nervous
but you're sure die here right right so
my career do or die here so my my tight
crew is ben if i lose this one christian
allen there's a shout out
trevor whitman
there he is trevor and then you also got
leester bowling dude so i got the squad
behind me yeah man
um and this is a straight-up all-out war
that's a that's a tiny guy who has to
keep two different
but what i was told before i want and
see he has a chin so chase gormley tried
out for the ultimate fighter we were
buddies there but he didn't make the cut
so i was familiar with him and he's a
very very good wrestler
head like a water buffalo so this
i don't know what see he said right away
but see now this is the inexperience i
knock him down right away and then it's
just
it's off to the races look at this i
mean just a blitz dude now we can have
fought
another minute as like at this pace but
these are two giants his first fight in
the ufc look at this man you're lighten
them up and i thought about pulling a
guillotine there and then i said [ __ ] it
i couldn't miss his head is so big
so big it's like hitting a [ __ ] barn
dude
you're punching a barn try not to miss
his chin but look at this pace dude is
this cree j dillashaw and 2004
connecting i'm blasting there you hit
him in the back of the year and that wow
he's now he's a little out of it
blasting them that's a big guy i was so
relieved and shane and nate uh nate mark
carter and shane caron are ringside so
look how loud the crowd is yeah again
your hometown boy that's why i i want my
ring of fire belt there you don't have
eight you don't have a mark i don't get
touched your nose is nice and pointed i
was so relieved and that's joe silva
and i was telling him i kept going i'm
telling you man i got this i'm telling
you i'm your next champ i got this all
right
hometown dude
i mean yeah you hadn't been fighting for
that long i had five fights boom no but
i'm saying how long have you been
training for two years
two years and i was in the ufc boom
i mean just you can't miss with that
head and look at the rookie enthusiasm
there you would have been gassed round
two right yeah but he was hurt there
yeah little [ __ ] but you did a lot of
running
i don't give a [ __ ] how much running you
did yeah at that point breathing at that
pace dude
that's me looking at shane and nate
dude you lose that because if so if you
lose on the ultimate fighter and then
they give you one more shot in the real
ufc you lose that one yeah you're in
trouble
your boy is probably selling supplements
door-to-door pursuit of happiness that's
crazy so that's a do-or-die fight i was
so nervous for that fight but i was so
relieved which means now you knew you
were going to keep
young joe rose
hair
and you're at home this is hard oh man
and they went nuts
now what's dope about this is i lit them
up so bad they played this fight on the
main card during the it was on fuel tv
oh they kicked off the fuel tv well it's
a good fight look at that oh jeez you
had a lot of confidence in your hands
back then oh yeah i mean i was golden
gloves champ boxer yeah i'm thinking
about i lit up roy even though i got
caught i still and i knocked out
everyone coming off the ultimate fighter
besides d'amico roger so
yeah
just squeezing but you know when you hit
when you hit at your size when you
connect with anybody's head it's just a
huge it's big trouble look how happy i
was yeah
and trevor was your trevor was your
[ __ ]
was your
this is me talking [ __ ] to dana you know
not talking [ __ ] just being like i got
this
i love it love what did you do after
that fight you were in denver i was in
denver
things get a little
spicy oh yeah i remember we had an after
party i mean you've earned it yeah i
mean you're a tall young good-looking
kid i know you dressed up i know you
were dressed to have a suit you didn't
have a mark on your face you can't put a
button down on nothing and then they
went cool you beat uh chase gormley and
now here's uh chris tush's shirt so the
the the
story behind chris tusher first of all
the scariest looking dude he looks like
a james bond villain he looks like jaws
remember the jaws of james bond villain
yeah so pause it real quick mike so
the thing about him that when i fought
him at this time he's 20 in one his
north dakota state wrestling champ uh
national champs he's from rugby north
dakota yeah rugby you don't get tougher
than yeah
yeah he's not watching youtube videos
he's he's you know he's milking cows and
getting yeah he grew up sucking he was
sucking on a cow's hutter that's where
all that milk went to the the calcium
went to his bones he's just [ __ ] he
faced like a bull shark okay he's built
like a bull shark 100 100 [ __ ]
that's that's a human bull shark now the
reason they paired me up with him is
because this was a big big ufc and this
was i think in er oh no it was in vegas
so this is in vegas but and one question
the main event was shane carl carwin
versus brock lesnar so i'm shane
carwin's little brother this is brock
lesnar's
best friend training partner so they
paired the two best friends training
partners to the main event now he's 20
and one he's 21 so it's not a great
fight for your boy no and he's fought
some of the toughest guys in the world
twenty and one oh my god now romero is
backstage nervous as [ __ ] and shane's
back then he's fighting brock lesnar and
greg jackson he could see how nervous i
was and greg goes let me talk to you
real quick what's up he goes what's the
worst can happen dude i mean what do you
mean he was it's not like he's jds or
you know kane vlasquez or chuck congo
he's not going to knock you out worst
thing that can happen
he wrestles you wears you out on the
ground that's it he's not getting ground
and pounding you have nothing to worry
about and he's like think about it
what's the worst kid having like
he takes him down and elbows my face
over and over he goes that's possibility
that's possibility
thanks dude thanks dude but what else is
about this is the day of the fight shane
carl was staying you know he's the main
event against freaking brock lesnar with
the greatest heavyweight fights all the
time should have stopped it early
whatever but um
i was nervous and i was like but i
always wanted to be alone i didn't like
being around other people because i was
agitated and whatever so i was like it
was a lone wolf during the day of the
fight but i was going crazy so i go up
into shane's uh suite and it's pat
there's so many people in there and
shane go shop get over here i'm like
what's up man he's staring out the
window we're at the mgm on there for you
just out the window and i was go hoping
to go up there and get like motivational
like talk or advice and he's just
staring out the window and there's all
the you know vegas there's other people
in the pool and there's girls and stuff
and guys drinking beer and he goes look
at there man i go yeah we're looking and
we're staring out the window he goes
look at them
they look like they're in fun right you
know looks like they're having a lot of
fun he goes more fun than us like way
more fun and he goes what the [ __ ] are
we doing i was like what
you're scared you're 265 pounds and and
people he goes what the [ __ ] are we
doing
yeah no doubt i'm gonna go back to my
room and then lisa had to go back he
goes i'm sorry about that man i don't
know shane's freaking out up there no
[ __ ] and he wore his heart on his sleeve
and he had a napoleon complex for a
giant guy in a lot of ways right yeah i
mean just he was aggressive as [ __ ] he
wasn't like jolly big guy the most
aggressive of all time yeah but this was
a big moment for just you know brock
lesnar and his background shane the
poster one of the biggest heavyweight
fights of all time shane obviously beats
the [ __ ] out of him for a round i mean
beats they could have stopped that yeah
but her dean being her dean didn't and
then obviously the right choice because
brock lesnar came back and choked chain
out shane gassed yeah
but dude adrenaline the adrenaline dump
and then his body got so full of lactic
acid they were thinking about rush him
in the emergency room he he was when he
came back to locker room you know it's
blood whatever but his the lactic acid
he couldn't move and his heart was going
boom jesus
and i remember dana came in right your
boy knocked him out in like a minute so
i'm a touch and i was like oh this is
crazy man i can't i was sad i started
crying because he lost but i was also
super current because i knocked him the
[ __ ] out yeah but i remember dana coming
in and putting his hand on uh shane's
chest going calm down calm down man
you've made more money than you've ever
made in your life you're a rich man calm
down
calm chain down calm down and then i was
like no doubt man what about me though
he's like get the [ __ ] off of me i'm
like okay i'll keep grinding
all right let's watch this and by the
way it's important to realize everybody
that back then when he was fighting the
drug testing was super strict and so
there were absolutely no drugs
[Music]
zero zero steroids drug dustin went like
this here are you taking stuff no cool
man have fun in there yeah and they
would have been mad if you got caught
too yeah they would have been mad so
just so and those that's now that's
brock lesnar's exact corner that he used
from that death clutch camp in minnesota
sure just a bunch of giant white guys
yep
giant white like vikings look at his
face i mean is that a bull shark yeah
that's the craziest [ __ ] ever that's who
you had to fight dude he looks like
bebop and rockstar rock study from
teenage mutant ninjas and and he had had
21 fights a lot of fights i had veterans
i had six of them you just got there
just got there you just got there and i
said all right here's a big deal this
guy's a monster equals ko's the
submission strong wrestler dangerous
ground and pound you play play football
here's some classes all right go ahead
and you're like what am i doing here i
don't know you guys locking the case ah
you'll figure it out yep that's right
now he has he had some
he had some tits on him and he was a big
dude
to 265 that's a big [ __ ] strong bull
of a man look at him and athletic you
can see it by the way by the way look at
how light he is on his feet that's a big
man light on his feet no neck he's got
no neck yeah so don't bother hitting him
no he looks like a spark plug yeah he's
now how tall is he
uh six two yeah not not sure but every
and earned every bit of that 265 had to
suck down from 265 probably
trying to get trying to get his
aggression going
this one i was early in my career the
aggression was there yeah because you
were competitive you'll see it you were
like here you go you didn't have an
option here right this was it oh this is
it and then also the
i was one of the first ones to wear that
hitman uh fight gear within the pink
because i always liked it different then
you see as the career goes along i start
rocking my own [ __ ] by the way and by
the way that hitman fight gear matches
your mouth your mouth was rather cool i
don't know what happened whole mouth
pull him out he knows yeah because at
this point pointy nose at this point
crow cop didn't give me a nose job
that's coming out he did not give you a
nose job you got a big old there's a
mall easton trevor your elbow's got a
little bit of a
hematum oh dude good call so my elbow
from training it filled up with fluid so
before this fight in the locker room and
in my uh
hotel room i was taking my own needle a
20 or 18 gauge needle and poking it and
drawing the fluid out because in my head
i was like if i get taken down i won't
be able to throw elbows yes and it was
like a [ __ ] cushion because the elbow
was so big right
yeah you you look would you weigh here
about 240 240 yeah a lot of vaseline on
your boy a lot of vaseline do they do
that still oh yeah okay oh yeah so you
don't get cut yeah
slit those shots with the house houses
he works with all the big boxers now
going gloves champion all wins by k.o
jiu-jitsu purple belt all wins by kale a
little misleading because i did choke
out again ultimate fighter all right all
right
i like that there you go dude you see
the left you're 26 26 27 here you see
the lexani sponsor on the back yeah i
took that deal they pay me uh the lowest
money ever got paid for my shorts but
then uh i just bought a challenger dodge
challenger and they gave me 22-inch rims
and that was the trade out
all black 22-inch rims you'll like when
you'll live on the edge you'll spend
that money on a car even back then when
you didn't have a lot of money you got
six dollars in the bag and you're like
i'm gonna get a charger four dollars on
the bank i'm gonna get a charge
challenger couldn't afford it really
needed to fight to pay that bill and
then shortly after that i decided to
take on a hummer h2 well you like to put
the pressure on yourself yeah like the
threat you're like a young bruce buffer
handsome guy by the way yeah he's always
been killing it
and we'll do the splits
he will do the splits hey so 18 when i
say 21 he's 18 and two not a bad record
these guys that that are looking over
his head here these guys look pretty
tough that's eric paulson who might be
the toughest guy that's the one who
taught yeah the one who taught uh brock
lesnar everything that's a rough guy
everything they're rough bunch
big boy too oh yeah i i don't know what
what a crazy job what a [ __ ] look at
my flyers
you're going to fight now dude actually
i got a real friend's store as a sponsor
max muscle hitman fight gear lexani
wheels knight rider jewelry which gave
me a ton of dope jewelry hire any of
them in business still that's the big
question
the young herb dean who looks exactly
the same now hitman was a byproduct of
tap out and off the tap out sold out the
beautiful iriana celeste who's still
doing the damn thing might look better
now might look better now yeah might
look better now
that black guy has a flat top so that's
a good sign there you go
yeah
look at this here we go so i just didn't
want to get taken out now a lot of
faints light on my feet a lot of jackets
i like you like your face
he's trying to take care of all right
i can see it so the game plan was a lot
of fun trying to stop your job into the
right hand and you i hit this [ __ ]
shrek guy with a one two from [ __ ]
denver colorado wow now now jabin is is
risky here because he's gonna go right
for a single it's you know what's going
on he made a mistake you know i was
offended because he was trying to strike
with me yeah i was offended because i
was like are you serious now here's the
other thing you see the blood in the
left hand not as athletic as you are
he's just not even close but when you
see the blood on the left-hand corner
there's nothing worse when you're
jogging around the octagon and the fight
before you was a bloodbath and then you
gotta jog around the blood and hit your
feet there's nothing worse than this
world you're like oh this is not a game
the blood between your toes some people
like sand between your toes nobody likes
blood between their toes just let you
know oh that's right i signed up for a
straight up steel cage fight yeah
doesn't get knocked out very soon here
yeah
oh oh
boom oh boy you just hit him right
straight with a one two and you just
caught him oh i was crazy there you go
that's the end of that
dust the shoulders off young
young cocky guy oh still looking good
you got it buddy okay well you still you
had a little set you were savvy and you
had some uh
you know you had some some showmanship
you got a broken nose there natural nose
you had a broken nose and right there is
where i said i said this kid could be my
podcasting partner you did let me mold
him boom oh that hurts he had to come
around the hand
hey he's got to keep his hands up huh he
wasn't ready for it just a lot quicker
though
now your reach i feel is longer than 78
yeah boom yeah right behind me right on
the temple
[Music]
daddy likes daddy likes i was so nervous
for that fight when i got back behind
the the drapes of the arena i got down
on my hands and knees and prayed dust
the shoulders off young man easy work
easy work
bad night for him good night for your
boy you kind of now i left from there
caller representing colorado there now i
left from there and i went to an after
party and i was in the uh elevator and
you know who's on the elevator with me
dwayne johnson the rock is that true
the rock was there did you say hi
because he's a fan of brock lesnar so he
came to the fight to watch brock lesnar
of course yeah i said hi and he was like
good fight man he's like that right hand
and i was like i was like oh this is
cool it's the rock and his thing look
down because we're about the same height
look down
here platform's on yeah your platform's
on really so you're not giving him six
four no no you give him six two uh six
two six three it's probably about an
okay platform okay i get it though maybe
it's just a shoe maybe just like that
boot with the thing on it but what you
just said just told me just now is that
you're taller than the rock and that's
all right i think naturally taller than
him yeah that's what you got from the uh
from your encounter yeah let's take a
little break from this flashback fight
night i just covered the chris tusher
sure fight which is a big deal for your
boy and next up is crow cop the infamous
crow cup before we do before we get back
to this glorious show breaking down some
of my most memorable fights with the old
man we talking about ranks brian cowan
i'm here to talk to you about peloton
peloton your boy's been a member for six
years my name on there is thick
boy prez that's my username on there you
see me on there putting in the miles
stay at home ride your bike they have
all sorts of stuff man peloton is
pushing you further with so much new on
the pelton bike and peloton bike plus
they have new classes new music new ways
to keep your workouts fun and motivating
they've also added boxing that's right
they got boxing you don't need gloves
you don't need any of that stuff man
discover a fast furious and fun workout
with pelton instructors in your corner
man also my favorite part of pelton is
the music man they have the new artist
series right now they've added so much
more music we're talking about from pop
rock hip hop edm there are over 100
artists all right you can choose from it
and you are you're just
blazing through the workout to your
favorite tunes man it keeps you
motivated alright it's easier to stick
to your goals when you keep your
workouts interesting and that's peloton
man pelton has a workout for every day
and every schedule de-stressed from a
long day with 30 minutes of strength 20
minutes of cardio do a quick 15 minutes
who don't have 15 minutes get their
thick bodies in shape man stay motivated
while having fun with the bike workouts
yoga meditation dance cardio box and so
much more your boy loves peloton man
that's why i started riding bikes
because i started with a peloton went
let's take this outdoors and i still
ride the peloton is so freaking fun and
it doesn't feel like a workout and your
boy burns tons of calories all right
visit onepelton.com to learn more that's
one peloton.com o n e p e l o t o n dot
com now let's get back to the show
now now murko is only 36 here
you know what i'm saying like it's not
like i'm fighting a 42 year old but you
look like you're murko that's a that's a
hard man right there and he's lived a
long time so i would say he dudes he
looks he's only 36 now i'm with and i
respect this man a great deal but he
looks so he looks a little younger than
me
yeah fair he's got a hard face
obviously i'm kidding but now this is in
new jersey this is in new jersey
and it was i think the third fight on
the main card bubba who is we got we got
trevor whitman i'm always in my
jiu-jitsu coach that's him that's why i
get my black belt from then that's lisa
i don't know why molly seems such a big
guy he's pretty tall um not really oh
okay no he's standing on a thing though
gotcha you know because that's yeah no i
know he's not tall i know he's not
talking he's not a big guy
he still competes in like masters just
determines and mops the floor with these
old kids he just won last year look at
look at you want to talk about a guy
who's bodied up
you want to talk about a man
across the [ __ ] board
are you kidding me now he hasn't had any
experience in this point right there's
no experience here okay now he has was
that 35 30. 40 fights at this point have
eight
so yeah so he doesn't know he doesn't
yeah okay because he's never seen a
young kid with a right hand before never
he's never seen anything you're gonna do
here he's not he's had no experience
now jon jones was the main event on this
card
who did he
fight i forget and his reason oh john
fought shogun to win the belt on this
card is his reached 82 i don't know
who cares though you know well i know
you have long arms not really not for a
heavyweight you don't not at all all
right i thought you did i thought your
arms were longer than no i thought your
arms were as long as john's all right no
god all right no
no no no
watch your head kick oh that's your hero
watch this i go you know for your head
kicks very cool i'm gonna kick off with
you show you a little bit of respect
here son
ready for this
trying to get i'm i'm happy with i'm
happy
oh right oh what you're known for look
at how that jab is educated that's a
nice job you're packing on the jab your
patent is hand down did you are you are
you a
young lomachamico are you a giant
lomachenko here trying dude
actually though your boxing looks great
yeah it really does oh yeah
light on your feet
big boy light on his feet now careful
now i thought i was gonna get him out in
the first round i'm not gonna lie to you
you well you were cocky at this point
you had your hand i like where your hand
is your hands protecting your chin right
there
he didn't really land much in unless
we're on the ground or against the cage
now i will say this i thought older man
i'm going to throw this croatian old
dude around wrong brennan because he's
built of steel and croatian power and i
could not move him well he's like he's
not the same this guy of all time his
legs are not skinny dude i've got
against shin carwin yeah gabriel gonzaga
yeah travis brown nobody was strong in
the murco crow cup
you've said that to me before i asked
you you're the strongest guy and you
said
is he made out of steel i don't know so
weird his balance is is oh dude his
balance was nuts look at that look at
him look at him he's looking at you
going hey hey what are you doing oh he's
he's smarter than everyone i thought the
head kick
now he's very good he he's very good in
the clinch now here's the thing here
this is the first time you see me use
wrestling absolutely but you're you're
chopping his legs up a little bit with
your that's not doing anything i'm
trying to stay busy now herb dean's
hating here and he takes he gives me a
warning here and then he takes the point
away because he's a huge [ __ ] hater
he can't be hitting him in the back of
the head they were
keep your [ __ ] hands keep your hands
in front of his ears i heard herbs mom's
croatian whatever
that well he could use a tan he could
use a ten he's croak out yeah but that
you just can't look at the body have you
seen a son dude his son's jacked i'm
sure that that's genetic oh oh get some
would say that that's a type of hell
about that some say that's true are you
kidding you he tried to come at you when
you football tackled him that wasn't
even a double leg that was a football
test he just came flying in i did the
good timing there oh yeah now this so i
i did the sea i'm trying to do this pass
that i've done non-stopping jiu jitsu
and you forget his oh up kicked me
pretty hard in the [ __ ] face
right in the [ __ ] face uh veteran but
that pass that i tried to do i worked
you kicking him look at you you don't
give you're you're not being respectful
to the legend mixed martial artist but
the thing is is that pass worked on
everybody black belt throughout
everybody's guard crow cop who's trained
by verdum and his defense is ridiculous
which i didn't take into account yeah he
um when i was trying to pass and push
down his leg he went oh you're gonna put
your hand back there i'm gonna punch you
in the [ __ ] face dude and then i have
to give up on the picture look at the
look at how busy you are and your wind
is good here this is crazy yeah my car
good i get pretty good down there you're
a nightmare here you're kind of a
buzzsaw and you're winning this fight
without question winning this fight
without question right now
and that's crow cop in in some would say
is prime or or not as private right
but now to my defense he did go on to
become a world champion after this thank
you
he won the k1 he dominated a lot no this
is a very real this is a very real crow
cop look at that now i'm pounding the
[ __ ] out wow holy [ __ ]
look at that i held the neck and
his defense was so good fighting for
maybe two years here yeah and you're
fighting croak up yeah but i mean that's
talent well
thank god you're done with this but you
you're good now the fans were not
pleased with the takedowns i'm getting
booed right well because they don't a
lot of them weren't they were kind of
though they wanted because that's
whether because i was considered a
knockout artist crow crops one of the
greatest knockouts all the time so when
you now you sweet see that oh boy tried
to sweep your boy there oh that was good
that was good that was good on marco
yeah that's very good now he goes to
work on your boy against the kj yeah his
elbows were [ __ ] filthy oh okay so
now he's going to start this fight
john fought shogun there's dana admiring
my work john fought shogun and became
the youngest uh light heavyweight
champion oh this is good the trip did
not work almost not almost gutsy
you're actually very strong for him
right now he's having a problem he's
like this young kid is trying to wear
his arms out
but then it's also wearing mine you got
that samoan speed
because you are samoan this is nuts
uh dude your your cardio is what i'm
impressed with here it's still the first
round my man yeah but you're you're
i'm breathing pretty hard yep and then
in the second round cro cop goes listen
dude cool story you're not tired i'm
going to shatter your nose into pieces
and you have to have major surgery after
this but also enjoy the blood rush when
i shatter your nose did you hear it
crack no i just remember i was like how
am i tired it's only the second round
and then
i just couldn't breathe through my nose
and the blood was rushing down my mouth
that's a great time when you don't want
to do this anymore that's a good time
and and making how much money he was
making how much and you were making i
made a mill for this i made 16 and 16.
hold on say that again remember this all
in my no no no
you made what 16 and sixteen sixty three
sixty but sixteen thirty two grand for
this i think might have been eighteen
eighteen either way it wasn't a lot also
trevor never were that shirt again for
me okay thank you yeah
those were the fight days back then you
had tap out you had affliction
wow wow i forget what they're telling me
here but it's basically like
boom good take down so you're definitely
in that first round right a hundred
percent i'm going to know we don't have
the same thing
in the third round but you give me that
first round 100 i give it to you i say
you're i say you're dominating this
fight at this point and so now you made
you got god damn it you're getting
president
all i'd be doing is going patience
patience that's stuff because the
crowd's blowing me and [ __ ]
yeah well and then i go hey guys he's
young calm down a pointy nose about to
get flattened out but right now he's got
his old nose calm down changed my nose
forever he did didn't he yeah he sure
[ __ ] did change that's not right
every time you look in the mirror you
think cro cop correct look at that
hairline look at that [ __ ] hair it's
still there teen wolf
up top and just a [ __ ] chick swinging
at me and then also smirking when i do
certain things and nobody knows that
yeah he's he's been here not a [ __ ]
talker oh dude i like your faint and i
like your jab
stepping in and out look at that
he's easy your boxing is on point man
it's all you cared about you didn't give
a [ __ ] about kicking you were like i'm
gonna box it if you throw a kick i'm
gonna punch you right in your grill i'm
not trying to kick as a heavyweight you
can kind of do that right you can make
him pay every time they kick you can wow
he pays in the end
yeah
oh well hey you blocked me off but look
at your boy
look at
oh a double leg
didn't want to that kick did scare me
and that's what i thought about all
night couldn't sleep
yeah but wow now the crowd here going
again because i took him down they want
a stroke because they don't know
anything there's kevin james right there
ladies and gentlemen kevin james
watching him and james watch me look at
that right there i heard him i love you
i heard you that's why i heard him yell
you could do comedy stop doing this why
are you doing this don't do this brian
callum has an amazing comic and my hero
wants to talk to you i heard kevin james
say you're funnier than me
get out of there man i don't think he
said get out of there hey i want to book
you my name oh there's another up kick
oh look it's an illegal upkeep you can't
now did i melt it here a little bit i
didn't realize it was an illegal upkeep
and then then your boy melted it for a
little bit of rest okay so now remember
he warns him here this second time
crocodile's done it then he warns me for
him in the back of the head then [ __ ]
herb dean soon here takes a point from
me but lets this fly
you tell me that's not a bigger deal
than me hitting rabbit shots in the back
of the head yeah you're you're again i
think herb dean's mom is from croatia
yeah i said well i've always called you
the rabbit and that's the only problem
is that you you you sneak those rabbit
shots you've done it to me and so i i do
have a problem with that i'm sure he
breaks my nose here pretty sweet because
i because i tried pummeling in and he
goes oh cool you let my left elbow go
i'm gonna shatter your [ __ ] stupid
nose oh oh boy he goes oh you live in
l.a right here
you live in l.a you want to get in show
business let me let me let me just let
me just give you a little something to
take with you for the rest of your life
he goes hey dude you don't need to go to
those botched doctors for a nose job let
me fix it for you this is the in croatia
we call this a crochet nose job that's
right and then he hits me with the
hardest elbow you've ever seen okay this
is there you go here you go and i don't
think you had full cauliflower ears at
this point yeah uh my left one was just
rumbling a little rumbling there's mike
goldberg joe rogan and joe silva mike
goldberg was a great commentator
right yep he was great yeah he was great
a lot of clinch game
turning each other around but this is
this is i remember i took him down early
in the round so you'd still i'd still be
winning the round right yeah give me the
round yeah 100 percent it could be the
round you're a little bit best friend
but whatever no no i'm i'm i'm not
actually biased here i'm not but yeah as
a as a non-biased fan listen well you've
taken them down
you've taken the only significant thing
that's happened in the fight correct but
also and i'm controlling against the
case this is a guy who knows his greco
who's a great wrestler comes up probably
in the russian system and you're you're
not letting him get the best of you here
he's trying to take me down there what's
up you guys are pummeling like a
[ __ ] you're holding this is
exhausting oh dude it's exhausting
exhausting he's getting a little tired
here
he doesn't look like it well i don't
think he you're you're stronger than he
is even though he's really strong he was
so strong yeah
yeah but you're a strong boy different
type of strong that's me resting there
i'm pretty tired at this point yeah and
he goes throwing his hips he goes oh
you're tired let me hit you with this
elbow it's coming up here it's coming up
now you can see i'm a little loosey
there it is oh that's the elbow ow
shattered my nose oh [ __ ] and right
there i'm like god why am i so tired and
the blood you'll see start seeping out
of my [ __ ] face oh and then he also
uh cuts uh me right above the eye come
on brendan let's go brendan you can't
breathe breathe out of your mouth bro
that's that'd be me in your corner
that's why i'm a mouth breather let's go
dude leave my nose you got this it's
gonna work out cause you're gonna do a
podcast look at my nose right there yep
you're gonna get into stand-up comedy
after this look at how you're bleeding
all over him oh my nose when i say
shattered i don't mean like that's
broken nose like off to the side i'm
talking in here fractured in many many
different
aftermath of that surgery fantastic for
the for the 10 days i had that splints
in my nose for 10 days that's a great
time god is it glorious when they take
those splinters oh cause you can't
breathe out any nose the whole time
it's so painful when they pack you and
unpack you oh
now i have a cut above the eye and look
he takes a point here for that i didn't
hit him behind the i got him on top
takes a point
herb takes a [ __ ] point look at this
so now i won the first
round that's give me the second round
you know what i'm saying no it's [ __ ]
crazy think about the when they take
points now
my face is pretty bust up now in the
judge's eyes though they're like oh one
kid's busted up so you oh yeah they
might be giving this round to crow cop
and then you take a point there's that
nice
infamous kick that he throws
42 right now your boy's in trouble can't
breathe nose is broken
yeah but you got you got heart you got
heart noses bro it's gonna have to kill
you yeah
oh nose is broken don't like when guys
like me say that he's gonna have to kill
you yeah it doesn't make sense no that's
gonna try and kill me because if this
were the death i would not sign up for i
was gonna say
i'm just
like i'm breathing hard right now i was
trying to take him out yeah look look at
this take down attempt leester bowling
taught you well dude dude wouldn't you
give me this round too i wouldn't do
this you get the takedown
but then you take it so
you
so i'm up one round
uh
remember they took a point away so that
nullifies around
i like your tits in this by the way i'm
very happy with your tits not bad right
i'm very happy with it those tits are
powered by lauren landau who's the
strength condition coach of the denver
broncos there you go and you're and
you're you're pumped right now you're a
young smooth i'm exhausted
uh never been in this much of trouble
never broke my nose like this never been
there with a vet of this caliber and i'm
like how the [ __ ] did i not get him out
fast enough cut over the eye
nose is so so smashed here they go watch
this
right on the [ __ ] tip of your nose
you know what didn't feel it though oh
jesus like right on the tip though
but you're not gonna give him a round
over here he pushed your bone into your
brain yeah look at my face is [ __ ] up
look at that cro cop trying to get
points look at you breathing out of your
mouth you're now a mouth breather thanks
crooker thanks crow cop i snore at night
you [ __ ] oh god
you probably have scar tissue still now
you have to get it clipped out you
didn't go for a follow-up because who
can do that i did
apparently i was supposed to get all the
the uh scar tissue cleared but i don't i
hated it so much worse than the dentist
you guys are both pumped very happy with
your physiques right now very happy
oh there you go oh ow
has illegally kicked me twice
and a nut shot and i got the point taken
away i'm still salty about it
again i think his mom was born and
raised that's a bad that's a bad kick
boom oh jesus christ dude no left you
know crop says left kick uh cemetery
right kick hospital yeah left kick to
the nuts daddy how many people mean left
kicked by cro cup to the other one stand
there for
out take a minute take a minute you're
not mad at the bod not at all very i'm
actually very happy with your body very
happy you're 240 there
you know
okay
your face is thin you don't have you
know everything is good here i'm very
happy oh there's that i think it's gonna
be that handy that's called island joe's
the one on my uh it'd be on my
left leg as we're looking at it now
that was a spa joe something that was a
sponsorship where after the fight they
flew me and the crew to hawaii
look at this though look at how busy you
are here look at this
heavyweights on the third round very
important uh honestly all [ __ ]
36 phenomenal shape phenomena phenomenal
shape but i mean
look at this it's called timing dude
look at the [ __ ] time to teach that
dude you can't teach that you know what
let me say one thing guys don't try this
at home please don't try this at home no
i'm trying the same passing keeps
hitting me in the [ __ ] face so i
don't know i didn't learn the first time
i'm not sure what you're doing there
you're you're you're sitting out almost
yeah breaking trying to break his legs
but you got to let go which you can do
if you're strong right you can no you
can do in jiu jitsu it doesn't work in
mma yes he'll punch you in the face yeah
another one
you're winning clearly
nobody would dispute that now here's the
weird thing about that timing you know
who else has that exact timing and
dominates who hold on lt gray my son oh
does he to a [ __ ] t is that right his
double leg timing is unreal is that
right unreal nobody can stop him
didn't teach him that it's just that the
helmet cc boy almost passed there i
could not [ __ ] pass his guard man
again verdum trained he's trained so
many years in this
used to the pride days we can do some
weird [ __ ] down there
definitely win the fight right uh with
that without to take [ __ ] so question so
one take down in the first one take down
the second pass the guard there when
half guard daddy likes daddy light he
knows he's lost third round
right now three minutes right now half
guard isn't bothering you
you can't feel that i think he gets it
back
and then i think the next time we get to
our feet
that's when that's when daddy unloads
you got to bleed on him a little bit
here well i'm going for a dog
go for a dark chair look at this pass
i'm trying to get him to bait him into
the darts there
now now
yeah you're young you're young and a
nightmare dude you're young and you're a
nightmare
look at the confidence god damn to get
up quick okay dude lorenzo fertitta and
join the fights chocoladelle ringside as
well right now you know you're winning
right you no no no you don't
how do you feel right here so you can't
be exhausted yeah i'm excited he's
exhausted she just got caught again yeah
i don't really care about those things
they don't really hurt me
but i'm exhausted
mainly because i can't breathe through
my nose this is what i go for another
takedown doesn't work out and there's
nothing more exhausting than failing at
a takedown yeah
yeah there you go you can tell i'm tired
making distance making distance yeah
he's tired but he's still he's still
functioning yep look at that block
stupid kick again
look at that block
i'm more tired now he's not throwing any
low kicks because he's he knows he's
gonna get blasted right there was a
couple but he that's all we train he's
gonna get double legged he's gonna get
but he knows because previous to this
fight which we can watch next time i
fought gabriel gonzaga and he had low
kick and i made him pay every [ __ ]
time his his low kicks were scarier than
crow cops actually gonzaga i've never
met a harry brazilian oh nightmare he
was a harry potter yes he was yes he was
dude name a hairy brazilian well he
he's a caveman yes he's a brazilian
caveman yes harry brazil he comes from
the caves of brazil dude i remember
fighting gonzaga and went through the
piss test i liked his piss it was all
brown
true story brown piss is that true i
don't know if he's dehydrated or kidney
supplements i don't know yeah again in
brazil back then there was knockout's
coming up daddy's oh
oh my god
lorenzo fertitta stood up now look at me
i do the face thing again krokop's a
zombie at this point
oh my god now people want to give me
[ __ ] cause i punched him while he was
down here's the thing that doesn't hurt
you gotta get faster hurry buddy no
that's that's what you do yeah that's
what you do what are you gonna do let
him get get his to get back up this is
cro cop dude you believe they didn't
give me knockout of the night you knock
out a legend and you don't get the
performance bonus of the night look at
this
boom he's going for a body kick there
daddy doesn't almost hit him with your
like with your palms look at this you
almost hit the meat of your hand right
same punch chris duster went down with
wow right on the temple behind the air
no no yeah
did you get a bonus for this oh
they gave it to somebody else which was
unreal and i think that's because dana's
hatred toward me afterwards
after beating crow cop wow and dude you
knock the legend out in ricochet and you
don't get a bonus now my mouthpiece was
custom made by unbreakable said showtime
not a big deal now what did you say to
him
what did he say to you
uh we're in the locker room this is the
first time when i realized that i didn't
really want to do this and i just told
him i said what the f because he was
beat up and i was like dude what are we
doing and he goes this is life i'm like
god is it though dude is it baby for you
man this is all you want to do i don't
yeah this is the first kind of seed in
my head where i was like i gotta figure
something boom
wow
oh and look at this
herb you gotta get me dude let me see
boom
punch crowd goes down cause herbs got
probably kind of nuts
look at joe silva going stop it all
right
okay
now krokop is not happy there no
no
that's a warrior he's recent that's a
warrior
and and bruce's hair went great during
this fight that was actually yes that
was actually so stressful to him that he
actually went gray
from during the fight this is the first
time he went gray so thanks brian look
at my nose already pretty [ __ ] up my
eyes swelled like a [ __ ] but you
feel fantastic
yeah you don't feel any of that now what
a good guy i don't know how much i love
him i started mma because of him i want
to trevor still don't wear that shirt
ever again
wow i can't forget my shirt not a big
deal look at rogan and his beard
look at rogan's beard shirt on
let's look at it
oh jesus bounced his head off i thought
you missed that second punch
ah [ __ ]
her her [ __ ] i want to make sure he was
dead it was a croatian zombie i'm not
even like you i thought he's gonna pop
up and fight me yeah back then it was
like no i know that i know that but it's
just like
even then i could see though a little
bit of this there was a little
hesitation oh yeah i gotta [ __ ] i
gotta do it dude i didn't want to get
back up no no no no i would have told
you to kill him i would have said jump
with both your feet on his chin let's
get the [ __ ] out of here i went after
that fight and i was in so much pain i
was throwing up i was in so much pain
and i went and ate uh chicken wings
that's how i saw that chicken wings are
good chicken wings back then you
celebrate now you celebrate with ferrari
back then you celebrated with chicken
wings how about i knocked out crow cup
can afford a ferrari back then no no no
no she couldn't afford it couldn't
afford a couch no right so that's okay
and this is what happens yeah and here
we are uh i'm glad we did this me too
man that was really fun we fun to watch
some of the losses like uh the travis
brown one a lot of insight there but
we'll do that that's right yep that's
right
that's right well you came to the
training camp with me yeah and you said
to me after you i went over that and you
came out and you went sorry
it's okay yeah nightmare it's all right
let's move on and then and rogan came by
me and he goes he didn't get hurt that's
the most important thing he needs to
retire his head's not into this
yeah okay right and then we had the
influence and we had infamous podcast
and you said don't let him talk to you i
kind of got set up on that list yeah you
said don't you said don't let him go
into like me retiring i won't i said i
just want to have fun i said but here's
what's interesting brian and i were
going to emergency podcast and he goes
dude rogan called me he wants to be in
on it
okay what's interesting about that that
jre which is his biggest one of all time
until he did the elon musk one
that wasn't a jre that was a fighter kid
yeah in jerry's studio that's what
people don't realize and you were the
one who said let's hear it yep oh
because at the time he was into it live
and wrong goes dude we don't have to
hear that that was brewed like not here
i still have a picture on my phone i
took a picture of you that day
and i said and i'm awesome i'm off uh
abbott yep and i said this is the lowest
point of your life right now i need to
take a blast gotta take a picture yeah
like this just sitting there like that
in front of groundworks groundworks off
off uh kenny no no
main street in uh
how you doing gotta take a picture of
you because you're you're what's that
yeah you're in the deepest trouble you
said take the glasses off let me see i
took him off giant black guy well you
still had an error for her [ __ ] media
and you knew that it's like this is me
yeah what can you do man that was fun
though
a little bit of work don't scare us i
get up i go hard like i'm george harris
make plays break lanes push weight break
chains go hard kick ass